another guy who we know and have known
is going to be on the trade block is
andy dalton the bengals quarterback and
ian rappaport of the nfl reported on
wednesday that
the bengals are
willing to work with dalton to
facilitate a trade to another team when
the time is right well when it comes to
a starting quarterback of course you
have to work with the quarterback you
don't just dump a quarterback onto
another team like a backup right tackle
if someone is acquiring a quarterback
that is going to be contending for the
starting job they need that guy to want
to be there the quarterback has to want
to be all in you can't have a
quarterback whose attitude is hey i'm
not showing up for any of the offseason
stuff i'm working out on my own i'm not
part of this i'm not coming early i'm
not staying late i'm not studying film
i'm not going to set the example for the
rest of the players on the roster no you
need the guy to want to be there you're
not going to trade a starting
quarterback who doesn't want to be
traded to the team he's being traded to
so the bengals were always going to work
with him the real question though
shireen is when is the time right this
is
just another example of what we've been
discussing the gm's out there who are
looking at the landscape of all the
quarterbacks they're going to want to
move and they're going to want to get
that spot filled and you know the
bengals may say the time is right after
we draft a quarterback especially if
they're thinking about trading down from
number one
and and letting someone else have joe
burrow and trying to pick up a tuatang
of iloa at pick number five if you don't
have andy dalton on the roster it's more
likely you're gonna get leap frogged so
maybe for them the time isn't right
until after the draft but i think it's
gonna be a lot harder to get value for
dalton if you wait that long i i think
that you know
to to maximize value as a free agent and
and or in a trade you got to be ready to
go march 18
when the free agency period opens in the
new league year begins
you know with with danny dalton uh it
all really reminds me of the ryan
tannehill situation from last year and i
don't think they get a whole lot for him
i think he goes somewhere where he could
be a backup quarterback
and you know the team that came to mind
right away when i heard this was the
chicago bears go back him up and and if
your starting quarterback starts to fail
you go hey we got a better guy sitting
there on the bench let's see what this
guy can do and i do think andy dalton
can play i see him going somewhere as a
backup quarterback i don't see him going
somewhere where he's gonna start uh as
come in as the guy who's gonna start for
that team so if you're gonna do that
you're not gonna get a first round pick
you're not gonna get a second round pick
so i it so reminds me of the ryan
tannehill situation and i think he goes
somewhere to a team that's looking at
that backup that maybe can come in and
take over if that starter starts to
struggle a little bit
here's the one caveat i'll apply to that
though shireen in this looming game of
quarterback musical chairs i still don't
think we know whether when the music
stops there's going to be more butts
than seats or more seats than butts and
there's a chance that there's going to
be a team
that is left because they waited too
long to have something lined up they're
going to be left looking around saying
who the hell is our quarterback for
2020. and if there's an andy dalton
that's still available in trade if
there's a philip rivers who is still
available in free agency that's when
maybe you end up getting more because
you waited because there's a team or two
out there that all of a sudden is
desperate and i keep coming back to the
patriots right they get left high and
try and i think this is why they want to
know what tom brady is going to do
because they're going to want to
implement their plan march 18. they
don't want to be that team that is left
wondering
what's our alternative to jared stidham
because we waited too long and everyone
else has been gobbled up so this is
going you know
we've never had anything even close to
this by way of potential chaos for
quarterbacks in free agency and really
through the draft and who knows how it's
all gonna play out there's gonna be a
major major shake up potentially watch
it's all everybody's gonna stay where
they are no i have a feeling that's not
going to happen it's going to be
somewhere it's going to be somewhere
between nothing changes and complete and
total chaos but i think it's going to be
closer to complete and total chaos
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports